president trump did not address the
surge of new cova cases yesterday
he did however say that attorney general
william barr is not working hard enough
to find evidence of election fraud barra
says the justice department has found
no evidence that mr trump lost because
of fraud paula reid has more on this
story
president trump on thursday would not
say if he had confidence in attorney
general william barr
asked me that in a number of weeks from
now
the tepid response came just two days
after barr told the associated press
the justice department had looked into
complaints about the election
but has not seen fraud on a scale that
could have affected a different outcome
in the election
they haven't looked very hard which is a
disappointment to be honest with you
because it's massive fraud
the courts have roundly rejected the
trump campaign's claims
because of a lack of evidence of massive
fraud
cbs news has also learned the president
was not happy about the article
and had a tense meeting with barr on
tuesday whether you go to wisconsin
where we just filed a case
or michigan or if you look at what's
happening in georgia
as an example of pennsylvania a few
hours after the president made that
claim the wisconsin supreme court
refused to hear a petition from his
legal team to overturn the results of
the election in the state
and kicked the case down to lower courts
to sort out
factual disputes the campaign says it
will continue to fight in wisconsin
and so far this litigation based on
false claims of a rigged election
has helped the campaign and the rnc
raise over 200 million dollars
since election day gail that's a lot of
money paula
now we hear the president is threatening
to veto a defense spending bill
that it seems his own party supports so
why is he doing that
well gail the president has threatened
to veto the national defense
authorization
act a bill that has been passed by
congress for 60
years unless lawmakers add a provision
limiting protections for social media
companies
but even members of his own party have
said that
has nothing to do with a bill that helps
fund the military
lawmakers do have a way to get around a
potential veto
it would require a bipartisan effort
two-thirds of the house
and the senate they have the votes but
so far it appears
they're calling the president's bluff
gail all right
thank you paula